Even though I walk through the valley of the shadow of death,
I will not fear for you are with me.
You are my light and my salvation.
You restore me and lead me for your glory.
I long to dwell in your house forever.
Good morning, church. It is such a pleasure and joy to be with you guys here,
uh, this morning. Uh, first, uh, I am Brandon. Uh,
I serve here as a boys ministry associate and so I get to hang out with the
students and I am a little biased,
but I do feel like I have the best job in the world. Um,
so shout out to students for letting me stick around as long as I have.
I'm very appreciative of you all, uh, and all the students out there. Uh,
today we'll be in Psalm 57. So if you have your Bible,
please turn there with me. Should be right in the middle of your Bible,
right in between, uh, the Book of Job and the book of Proverbs.
And as you're turning there, I wanted to give a couple of thank yous.
Uh, first I wanted to give you a thank you for all of your prayer. Uh,
last time I was here back in November,
I was in the midst of my finals week of seminary and
the final was the next day.
And I came before you all and asked for prayer and you know, it worked.
I was able to finish everything, uh, finish this semester out well.
And so next time I'm in a crunch,
I'll make sure I get on the preaching calendar and come back up here and tell
you guys about it. So thank you honestly for your prayers. The second thank you,
uh, I want to give is through just you guys as a church for the encouragement,
um, that, that you guys have given me as I've seen you and,
and the church and through email and text, uh, it has been, um,
a true blessing for me, um, to hear those kind words. And third,
I wanted to give a thank you to a group of people who I met with beforehand.
As I was prepping this psalm,
I just wanted to get more eyes on the text and I just wanted to see what the
Lord was revealing in their heart as they read it.
And so thank you for helping me put more eyes on the text. And,
and last but not least, I want to give a thank you to John. I know, know,
he is not here, but I want to just be thankful for the opportunity, uh,
to be up here. But I have to confess,
when I saw that I was preaching Psalm 57, I was not thrilled.
Um, I wasn't frustrated, but I was a little like, oh man, Psalm 57.
But there's a reason I'm not against Psalm 57,
but the last time I preached it was over Psalm 52.
And in Psalm 52, I look at these situations.
I I look at David's life, I see what he's going through,
and it doesn't come from a joyful or cheerful
circumstance. When I look at Psalm 57 and Psalm 52,
they actually come from pretty much the same situation in David's life.
He's on the run, Saul is hunting him.
When I look at Psalm 57,
I see that they come from a heart that is going through it.
The Psalm arises from a heart that is exhausted,
a heart that is only standing up by leaning on the everlasting arms.
And you know, selfishly,
I would love to preach a psalm where David just got done conquering enemies and
he is riding again on cloud nine or or Psalm 23,
any, anything, the psalms that we, that we grew up with and we love to recite.
But the more I've looked at it in red,
Psalm 57 and I see these storms of destruction which
come at a great time after last night, I,
I start to see that this is real life.
What David is going through is real.
And we need to talk about where God is during the midst of storms
because life is hard
and sometimes things happen that are completely out of our control.
But don't hear me say that life is one big storm and we should walk around like
EO and and just all walk around listening to Nirvana music,
that there are so many joyful seasons in life, but there are storms.
There are times when we feel beat up like the enemy is
simply eating our lunch, for example.
Maybe finances are strained right now and you can't imagine how you're
gonna make it through.
Or maybe you're dealing with loss in the family or you're preparing for a loss
to come.
There could be sin in your life that you are fighting to overcome,
but you keep falling back and you just feel the weight.
And for some of us in this room today, father's day is a storm.
This is a hard day for people. It can be a hard day for multiple reasons,
but honestly, maybe it has nothing to do with your earthly father, father,
but maybe you feel like your heavenly Father has abandoned you.
Maybe you feel like you are left on your own
at the end of your line and you're giving God one more chance to show up.
This is real life. And as for me,
as I've looked over this psalm, it's been a breath of fresh air.
Here's why.
Because this psalm can fully acknowledge that there are storms in our life.
There are attacks and fears all around us.
When David is writing this psalm, he's on the move to the cave.
And we can see what David saw in one Samuel 22, 1 through two.
It says this,
and David departed from there and it escaped to the cave of Al Adom.
And when his brothers and all his father's house heard it,
they went down there to him and everyone who was in distress,
everyone who was in debt,
and everyone who was bitter in soul gathered to him and he
became commander over them and they were with him about 400 men.
David was surrounded by people who needed encouragement and to be
reminded that the God who is most high is still most high,
David a knows around him,
needed to see that God's faithfulness abounds and it far exceeded their
comprehension so they could trust him.
We did the same thing this morning and so read with me Psalm 57 and let's see
what the Lord has for us today.
Be merciful to me. Oh God, be merciful to me.
For in you my soul takes refuge in the shadow of your wings,
I will take refuge till the storms of destruction pass
by.
I cry out to God most time to God who fulfills his purpose for me.
He will send from heaven and save me.
He will put the shame him who tramples on me.
God will send out his steadfast love and faithfulness.
My soul is in the midst of lions. I lie down amid fiery beasts,
the children of man whose teeth are spears and arrows,
whose tongues are sharp swords, but be exalted. Oh God, above the heavens.
Let your glory be over all the earth. They set a net for my steps.
My soul was bowed down, they dug a pit in my way,
but they have fallen into it themselves.
My heart is steadfast. Oh God, my heart is steadfast.
I will sing and makem melody awake my glory, Waco harpin liar.
I will awake the dawn. I will give thanks to you, oh Lord,
among the peoples.
I will sing praises to you among the nations for your steadfast love.
It's great to the heavens, your faithfulness to the clouds. Be exalted. Oh God,
above the heavens. Let your glory be over all the earth. Let's pray. Lord,
thank you for this time.
God thank you that we can come and worship you together. Lord,
I simply pray that you help us see you more clearly. Your name we pray. Amen.
So where do we find ourselves in Psalm 57? Well, like Phil mentioned last week,
Psalm 56 through 60 were all midterms and they all have to
do with David being under pressure,
under attack and needing deliverance.
And in 57 we see that David was on the run for his life against the current
king who commands all of these armies
and he's dedicated to killing David. David simply out of jealousy.
And the only reason he wants to kill David is because the Lord has anointed
David King and he has rejected Saul.
And I'm sure thoughts may have crossed David's mind like, okay, God,
why would you even put me in this situation if you knew God,
if you knew Saul was gonna come after and chase me,
Maybe David was just fine doing a safe job as a shepherd.
But also we know in the Bible that when David was a shepherd,
he would always fight off lions and bears when they took a sheep.
So maybe David was just built for this moment,
but now he finds himself on the run
being chased by the king and his men and
he's hiding in a cave. It's dark,
it's cold. David is far from home.
But at the same time, on the outside looking in,
we can see that David is in a cave. He's safe in a way.
They have a home base, they have somewhere to run.
But David knows the cave that he's in this physical cave is not his refuge.
Well, how do we see that? Look again, verses one and two with me,
he pleads to God and says, be merciful to me for in you my soul takes refuge.
David knows this is not a game of hide and seek.
David feels this in his soul and knows that a mere physical cave will
not protect him.
David is looking to get under the shadow of the Lord's wings and hide
himself. He is crying out to God to deliver him and to save him.
And so if David was finding his refuge and protection from this cave,
then why would he come before the Lord?
David knows the cave is not his refuge because
God is his refuge.
How about us? When times get hard,
when you're frustrated, when you're tired, where do you find your refuge?
Where do you put your trust in a refuge?
Simply put is a condition of being safe
or sheltered from the pursuit of danger.
And so when I ask that question, when you feel like you are being attacked
or under pressure or you're filled with fear,
where do you turn for safety?
What do you think will give you the rest and relief that you are longing for?
And as I've looked at this text and had the rest with this,
I've had to be honest with myself and say that I often turn to everything
but God,
I try and find safety in the things on this earth and not the God of the
universe. For example,
food can be a refuge and a very tasty,
delicious refuge.
And I know of many fathers who are will be partaking in a lot of food after
we're done here And food is good, don't get me wrong.
But food does not sustain us maybe for a little bit.
But what we don't find in this psalm is David's stress eating his problems away.
David knows the cave is not his refuge.
He knows nothing on this earth can protect him and bring him true rest outside
of God.
Or maybe there's something in our life that we seek security and safety and
there's actually sin against God.
We think that we know better than God. And if we do this,
then we will be satisfied and all of our fears and worries will be gone.
And as someone who has done this time and time again,
I can promise you that our sin does not make a good refuge.
And what we need to know and what can encourage us today is what David saw.
He saw God as his refuge and David was determined to
hide himself in the shadow of the Lord's wings.
He knew the situation was out of his control,
but he knew his God had control
and David wasn't the only one.
We can see all the way back in Genesis with this guy named Joseph who
continued to trust in the Lord and find refuge in him even when his brothers
wanted to kill him. And then I guess they settled to just sell him into slavery
And he still hid himself in the Lord. When he did the right thing,
he made the right decision.
But he still gets sent to prison for something he didn't even do.
And when he had helped someone get out of prison to interpret dreams,
it seemed like that there was this light at the end of the tunnel,
but yet he had to keep waiting and waiting. But through it all,
he continued to trust in the Lord and seek refuge in him.
And then if we go to the New Testament, we see Jesus as he's fasting,
he continues to trust in the Lord as well.
So how do we get there in the face of danger
when we're tired in the face of persecution, when we're hurting,
how can we turn to God to protect us? Well,
if we take notes from this psalm,
we can see that through this imagery that David wants the people to see that God
is most high,
God is most high. Where do we see it?
I'm so glad you asked. Look at verse two with me.
He directly calls God most high. He says, I cry out to God most high,
Which is a name for God.
We first see in Genesis when Abraham says that I have lifted up my hand
to the Lord God,
most high possessor of heaven and earth,
there is nothing higher than God.
Any rules over it all.
David wants to take refuge into one who holds heaven and earth in his hands.
Because what threat can compare
since God is most high,
then we can see the confidence that David has as he says in verse three,
that God will send and save him.
God will put to shame thoses who trample over him.
God will send out his love because God is most high.
And if David was unsure about any of this,
then he would've ran somewhere else for protection.
But he understood that the God he worshiped was the one who was over it
all. David understood that if the Lord had a purpose,
then he would fulfill it. And there was nothing,
no one or anything on earth that could stop that.
And later in the Bible and the book of Isaiah,
God gives us a glimpse into his majestic character. And Isaiah, oh boy,
46, 8 through 11, we see this. This is God speaking.
Remember this and stand firm,
recall it to mine you transgressors.
Remember the former things of old for I am God and there is
no other. I am God.
And there is none like me declaring the end from the beginning and from ancient
times things not yet done saying my counsel shall stand
in. I will accomplish all my purpose. Calling a bird of from the east,
the man of my council, from afar country,
I have spoken and I will bring it to pass.
I have purpose and I will do it.
What a big and mighty God we serve.
Do we see him like that? And you see,
if we go back to David's early life when he's face to face with a literal giant
names Goliath, here's what he says. Up they go back and forth, forth.
And first Samuel then David said to the Philistine,
you come to me with a sword and with a spear and with a javelin,
but I come to you and the name of the Lord of host,
the God of the armies of Israel,
whom you have defied this day,
the Lord will deliver you into my hands and I will strike you down and cut off
your head.
And I will give the dead bodies of the host of the Philistines this day to the
birds of the air, to the wild beasts of the earth. Don't worry,
we don't say that part in the hillside kids version,
That all the earth may know that there is a God in Israel and that all
this assembly may know that the Lord saves not with sword and spear for
the battle is the Lord's and he will give you and to our hands.
Do we walk around with that same confidence when it comes to God?
Like I said, the reason I believe David could run to God as his refuge
is because he saw how big God was.
He saw that God was most high.
David grew up hearing the stories about how God's power at the Red Sea,
David grew up hearing about how God was able to send manna down from heaven.
David grew up hearing about these conquests where it looked like Israel was
gonna lose. They were clearly outnumbered,
but God showed up big
so David was able to take refuge and the God who was most high because nothing
was bigger than God.
And if David was alive after the year 1885,
then I'm sure he would join all of the saints and sing,
oh Lord my God,
when I in awesome wonder,
consider all the worlds thy hands have made.
I see the stars, I hear the rolling thunder. Dear
Thy power throughout display
then sings my soul,
my savior God to thee how great thou art,
how great thou art.
If you have put your faith in Jesus and call yourself a Christian,
then we need to fight against having small views of who God is.
Why would we run and put our trust in a God we're unsure,
has the power to show up? So let me ask you the question,
what is going on in your life where you need God to show up
as you're thinking about it? Do you think that's too big for God?
Do you think these situations are outside of his control?
Does the pressure weigh on you and the fear weigh on you so hard that you simply
need relief and you don't care where it comes from?
Can you relate to David in verse four when he says,
his soul is in the midst of lions and when he lies down,
he's among the beast. And when he looks around,
he sees the children of man have teeth that are arrows that are waiting to
penetrate his soul. That is you today.
If you have felt this way before,
our hope is found in God who is most high, the God who saves
And nothing else can deliver you because nothing else has the power or authority
to. So like David and many of our other heroes in the faith have done and our
ultimate hero,
Jesus Christ take refuge in the Lord who is possessor of heaven
and earth. But in this psalm,
we see more than just God's power and majesty on display.
We can see his faithfulness.
We can trust God as a refuge because God is faithful.
It was one thing for David to see how powerful God was,
but he also needed to see that God was faithful.
So growing up in Oklahoma and traveling anywhere in the world and telling
someone you're from Oklahoma, they always have one question they ask you.
It's always the first. I promise o U or osu,
that's all anyone cares about when it comes to our great state.
And I'm not here to pick a fight at all. I'm not gonna answer that question,
but I will say this,
I've always had a hard time watching college football and enjoying college
football. Uh, for the sole reason that um,
they all leave. Uh, obviously no one can play for a team forever,
but with college it felt so short lived. Like one second they're here.
Maybe they win Heisman,
maybe they win you a conference championship and you blank and they're gone.
They're off in the N F L,
they're off playing for another team across the country and you're lucky to
catch 'em on Sundays.
And we're so proud and excited for their next step. But it still hurts a little.
Um, you started the roof for someone, you're following them,
you love them and they're gone.
And then you have to get emotionally attached to the next great player,
however long that may take. And you see,
God is not a one and done prospect.
God is not waiting for the next best opportunity to come,
but he's faithful through generations.
And this sounds familiar to Exodus 34, 6,
the Lord, the Lord of God,
merciful and gracious flow to anger and abounding
in steadfast love and faithfulness,
keeping steadfast love to thousands from generation
to generation. God is faithful to his people.
Mourning by mourning mercies we see great is thy
faithfulness.
David saw that not only was God powerful enough to be his refuge,
but he saw that he was the faithful refuge.
Look at the text again with me in Psalm 57, 3
he says,
and he sees the utmost confidence that the Lord will send out his steadfast
love and faithfulness. And if we drop down to verse six,
he sees that they have dug a pit for me,
but they have fallen into it themselves.
And then jumping to verse 10,
we see that God's faithfulness and love is great to the heavens
and far exceeds our comprehension. It is above the clouds.
And if we look at verse three and 10,
we can see the word in our English translation. It says steadfast love.
But when we translate it back to Hebrew, we can see that that word is Hess said,
hopefully I'm saying that right, Phil can correct me later.
But this word is a word that is used about 250 times in the Old Testament.
And it is a number one, uh,
number one word that God uses to describe himself.
God shows his abounding unfailing love or has said to his
people,
listen to the description of God's faithfulness has said surpasses
ordinary kindness and friendship.
It is the inclination of the heart to show amazing grace to the one who is
loved. It runs deeper than social expectations,
responsibilities and emotions or what is deserved or earned by the recipient.
And it finds its home and committed familial love and it comes to life
and actions.
There is no other refuge that can be as faithful as our God.
Throughout all of the circumstances in David's life,
he was able to see that God will not leave his side.
David was able to trust in the almighty power of God,
but also God's nearness and God's love and God's mercy.
He shows the sinful people.
So if we look for rest and security and safety and tr trust outside of God,
then we will be satisfied.
Every other refuge we run to only be
unreliable. So lemme ask you the question,
where do you run for refuge?
Do you run to the almighty faithful God who has made himself our refuge through
the storms of destruction?
Or do you run to a false refuge?
Do you run to a place that promises,
promises you rest but can never fulfill you?
And maybe you're sitting in this room today and you can't even wrap your head
around the fact that we could run to the God of the universe to seek safety and
protection and trust.
Like why in the world would God want me to run to him? Well,
we see David doesn't appeal to God based off his own merits.
God is not David's refuge because David's some standup guy.
Look again at the first verse in Psalm 57. David says,
be merciful to me. I need your mercy.
And if we go back to last week's Psalm and 56 1, it says,
be gracious to me God.
David is asking for the Lord's grace. So why do I say all this?
Because if you are in this room and you are at the end of your rope and
everything else has failed you,
you can run to the Lord for your refuge and you can hide under the shadow
of his wings.
And you don't need to feel like you need to clean yourself up or get yourself
right.
You
God is our refuge because of his great mercy and love for us.
How great is that?
We have the faithful refuge in God,
the Father based solely on mercy and grace.
Mercy and grace that we all need today ends every day
because time and time again we forget God.
And we wouldn't say that we just God like he's gone from our memory,
but we maybe we have an inaccurate view of who God is.
And so we don't trust him and we don't make him our refuge
and he isn't our help in the midst of storms when people are
surrounding us and they have these nets set up for us to fall in.
Our heart isn't always on the Lord,
that as I read through this text,
the someone who is still praising God
even while being attacked.
When I read through this text and I see someone giving thanks to the Lord in
singing, I see someone trusting in the Lord fully.
I'm reminded of Jesus Christ.
His heart was always set on God and he never found refuge
anywhere else but in God the Father.
And so what Jesus did here on earth makes it possible for us to make God our
refuge today even though we have turned away from God time and time
again. Jesus never did.
Jesus always made God the Father his refuge.
And so if you have put your faith in Jesus,
you can run to God as your refuge because of what Jesus did. And if you haven't,
you are invited to today.
And my prayer is that God would help you see him more clearly and you could
trust him as your refuge.
But there's one more point for believers in the room,
those who have trusted in Jesus.
There's
One more thing we need to see.
While the context of this psalm may come at a not so great situation,
David's on the run for his life. He's scared.
He doesn't know what's gonna happen.
David doesn't stay there and neither should we.
And so whatever you walked in here with, however this weekend went,
however June has gone for you,
I don't think we should stay in this, this storm,
but we should move to praising God. Look at verses five and 11 with me.
Even through everything that is going on, the Psalm breaks in verse five,
look, it says, be exalted. Oh God, above the heavens.
Let your glory be over all the earth.
This is as his soul is in the midst of lions.
And then in the end at verse at verse 11, he finishes, finishes it saying,
be exalted. Oh God,
above the heavens that should glory be over all the earth.
Same line.
David breaks in the middle despite his circumstances and praises God.
So what I believe David wanted to communicate to the people and the listeners is
that we should praise God even in the storms,
David was so sure of the Lord's protection and deliverance,
that he was moved to sing and to dance and praise the name of the Lord.
So what we should do today is we should join David by praising God.
Join David by praising God.
Well why was David praising God and why should we?
Well the answer is because a better day is coming.
David trusted in the Lord and knew that it would work out,
but he never saw Jesus. And being on this side of history,
we know that we will not need to take refuge forever.
The gospel tells us there is a life after this one.
The gospel tells us that Jesus will come back.
And that is why we should praise God,
because Jesus will reign on the throne forever and make everything
right. Jesus will turn our mourning to dancing.
And like David says in verse three, and since we're on this side of history,
we know that Jesus will sin from heaven and save me.
Jesus will put the shame him who tramples over me.
Jesus will be faithful. So while yes,
we take refuge in the Lord today
and we can trust him because he is most high and he is faithful.
One day there will be no more storms.
There will be no more destruction.
This is how the story ends in Revelation 21, verse one through eight.
Mrs. John speaking. He says,
then I saw a new heaven and a new earth
for the first heaven and the first earth had passed away and the sea was no
more. And I saw the holy city,
new Jerusalem coming down out of heaven from God prepared as a bride
adorned for her husband. And I heard a loud voice from the throne saying,
behold the dwelling place of God is with man.
He will dwell with them and they will be his people
and God himself will be with them as their God.
And he will wipe away every tear from their eyes. And death shall be no more.
Neither shall I be mourning nor crying nor pain anymore.
For the former things have passed away.
And he who was seated on the throne said, behold,
I am making all things new. Also, he said,
write this down for these words are trustworthy and true. And he said to me,
it is done. I am the alpha and the omega,
the beginning and the end to the thirsty.
I will give from the spring of water of life without payment to the
one who conquers will have this heritage and I will be his God and he will be my
son. But as for the cowardly,
the faithless to the testable, as for the murderers, the sexually immoral, sorc,
idolaters, and all the liars,
their portion will be in the lake that burns with fire and sulfur,
which is the second death. Pray with me church.